Technoautism still exists, but I want to say that it was more of a default. It was the idea that the future means progress. The 21st century is somehow, if we can just get past this small issue of maybe wiping ourselves out, if we can get past that, then the 21st century, maybe we grow up. It's a kind of a Star Trek universe. It's like we get to a point and all of the potential is unleashed, all of these possibilities. And this is not just sort of saying, you know, flying cars and stuff. like that is it's much deeper in terms of like thinking about utopias and along those lines
技术乐观主义依然存在，但我想说，它曾经更像是一种默认设定。那是一种认为未来意味着进步的观念。21世纪在某种程度上——如果我们能克服可能自我毁灭这一小问题的话——如果我们能跨过那道坎，那么21世纪，也许我们就能成熟起来。这就像是一种《星际迷航》式的宇宙。就像我们达到了某个临界点，所有的潜能都被释放，所有的可能性都展现出来。这不仅仅是指飞行汽车之类的东西，它在思考乌托邦以及类似方向时要深刻得多。
and there was genuinely a sense in the 70s and 80s I can't speak for the 60s I was not really there only vaguely present but 50s and 60s you know the Jets and view of the future and you just see it in the science fiction of the time welcome to a ADSP, the podcast, episode 264 recorded on December 11, 2025. My name is Connor, and today I chat with Kevlin Henney live from Yao 2025 in Sydney, Australia. We chat about aphantasia, anendophanesia, synesthesia, techno-optimism, the future, and more. All right, we are here. I actually don't remember what episode this will be.
在70年代和80年代，确实存在一种这样的感觉——我无法代表60年代，因为我当时并没有真正参与其中，只是模糊地存在着——但50年代和60年代，你知道，杰森一家（The Jetsons）对未来的展望，你可以在当时的科幻小说中看到这一点。欢迎来到ADSP播客，第264集，录制于2025年12月11日。我是康纳，今天我将与凯夫林·亨尼（Kevlin Henney）在澳大利亚悉尼的Yao 2025现场进行交流。我们将讨论心盲症、内言缺失症、联觉、技术乐观主义、未来等等。好了，我们到了。我其实不记得这是第几集了。
I think it's episode 264. The last time you heard from us, folks, it was October 10th. We've been releasing episodes for weeks now. And it is now December 11th, soon to be released on December 12th. So you went from very stale audio or recordings to now fresh. And we're here with four-time guests, I think. We cut your last episode in the four parts with Kevlin Henney. and we are, we just both finished speaking for, uh, what was the third installation of three different
我想是第264集。各位，上次你们听到我们的声音还是在10月10日。我们已经连续几周发布剧集了。现在是12月11日，很快就会在12月12日发布。所以你们从非常陈旧的音频或录音，现在变成了新鲜的内容。我们这里有四次做客的嘉宾，我想是这样。我们把上次和你凯夫林·亨尼的剧集剪成了四部分。我们俩刚刚结束了三场不同会议中的第三场演讲。
conferences. We were at Yao, 2025. We were first in Melbourne, then we were in Brisbane or as been, I've been told, Brizzy. That's how they call it. And now we're in Sydney. And we're gonna, we're gonna talk. I mean, for, for folks that haven't listened to your first, uh, four-part episode, and that might not be familiar. I mean, I can introduce a little bit one of my favorite speakers. I just had, I've been reminded that you are the author of several books, including my favorite 97 things every programmer should know and every Java programmer should know. And I think there, I know there's a couple of the 97 books. I don't know if you're co-authors on those ones. I don't think so, yeah. But a veteran of the speaking track. And we're going to talk
我们参加了Yao 2025。我们先是在墨尔本，然后去了布里斯班，或者正如人们告诉我的，叫“Brizzy”。他们就是这么叫的。现在我们在悉尼。我们要聊聊。我是说，对于那些还没听过你那四部分剧集、可能不太熟悉的人，我可以稍微介绍一下，你是我最喜欢的演讲者之一。我刚刚被提醒，你是多本书的作者，包括我最喜欢的《程序员必知的97件事》和《Java程序员必知的97件事》。我想还有几本“97件事”系列的书，我不知道你是不是那些书的合著者。我想不是，是的。但你是演讲界的资深人士。我们要谈谈
about maybe the talk that you gave at this conference and also an NDC and I think at a different conference. But also, we're going to have to talk about the talk that you gave a go to Copenhagen. but anyways, before we get into that, and we're going to have to talk about Afantasia a little bit because we've been chatting about that. But before we get to that, maybe I'll hand the mic to you and you can color in the bio bits that I missed just in case we had a new listener
也许是你在这个会议上做的演讲，还有在NDC以及其他会议上的演讲。但我们还得谈谈你在哥本哈根Go To大会上的演讲。但无论如何，在我们进入正题之前，我们得稍微谈谈心盲症，因为我们一直在聊这个。但在那之前，也许我把麦克风交给你，你可以补充一下我遗漏的个人简介，以防有新听众。
since the last time you're on. Okay, so, yeah, I edited a bunch of books. I contributed to the 97 Things series, pattern-oriented software architecture books as well. I've been a columnist and a blogger and all kinds of bits and pieces, and occasionally it can be found running workshops and doing various bits and pieces for people. I guess that's it. Yeah, you can
自从你上次来之后。好的，是的，我编辑过很多书。我为《97件事》系列做过贡献，也参与过《模式导向软件架构》系列书籍的编写。我一直是个专栏作家和博主，做过各种各样的零碎工作，偶尔也会为人们举办研讨会和做各种事情。我想就是这样。是的，你可以
normally run into me either somewhere on the internet or at a conference. And yeah, fantastic, I mean, like I said, one of my top three speakers. And I think, I don't, I actually, off the top of my head, I don't know if I can rank, but if I had to choose one, and you've probably heard me say this, but you might have forgotten a declarative thinking, declarative practice. Is that the title? So this was a talk now. It's got to be given at least six, seven years, plus. ago because this was one of the first talks that I watched when I started watching online talks. And it's link in the show notes, folks. We'll link all the talks, but it's a great talk. So where should we start? Should we start with Afantasia's anesthesia, or should we start with
通常在互联网上的某个地方或会议上遇到我。是的，太棒了，就像我说的，我心目中前三名的演讲者之一。我想，我其实，凭记忆，我不知道我能不能排个名，但如果非要选一个，你可能听我说过，但你可能忘了，关于“声明式思维，声明式实践”。是这个标题吗？所以这已经是至少六七年前的演讲了，因为这是我开始在线观看演讲时看的第一批演讲之一。节目说明里有链接，各位。我们会链接所有的演讲，但这真是一个很棒的演讲。那么我们从哪里开始呢？我们是从心盲症、联觉开始，还是从
the go-to Copenhagen talk? Or should we start with, yeah. What should we start with? Okay, let's talk about the, let's talk about the feely stuff, first of all. So we've been talking, so the conversations that have been going on have been very much about how we sense the world differently, how we experience the world differently. And the, it's come up in the context. It turns out that I am colourblind and so is Kent Beck, who is one of the other keynote speakers here. And technically we're both red-green colour-blind, but we actually have different versions of colour-blindness in terms of who perceives red, who perceives green. But in addition to being colour-blind, I'm also synesthetic. And synesthetic means you have cross-sensory wiring. And in a lot of
哥本哈根的Go To演讲开始？或者我们从哪里开始？好吧，首先我们聊聊那些感性的东西。我们一直在讨论，这些对话很大程度上是关于我们如何以不同的方式感知世界，如何以不同的方式体验世界。这在对话中被提到了。事实证明我是色盲，肯特·贝克（Kent Beck）也是，他是这里的另一位主旨演讲嘉宾。从技术上讲，我们都是红绿色盲，但实际上我们在感知红色和绿色方面有不同类型的色盲。但除了色盲之外，我还有联觉。联觉意味着你的感官神经连接是交叉的。在很多人身上，
people the typical one and one that I have is a fairly run of the mill is that I associate colors with digits digits and letters so therefore when I think of a number it also has color associations when I think of a word it has color associations helps me remember my hotel room and things like that which what's my room number as you get some weird cross wiring like that but then you get this weird stuff that the conversations have gone off in terms of like how unique a person's experience of the world is and that we make a number of assumptions about how other people perceive the world. Normally it's based on our own experience and we have a lot of things that we share culturally. So common experiences that we have is how we hear things and how we taste things and we know
典型的一种，也是我所拥有的一种，比较普通，就是我将颜色与数字和字母联系起来。因此，当我想到一个数字时，它也有颜色关联；当我想到一个词时，它也有颜色关联。这有助于我记住我的酒店房间号之类的事情，比如我的房间号是多少，你会得到一些奇怪的交叉连接。但随后你会遇到一些奇怪的事情，对话已经偏离了方向，讨论一个人对世界的体验是多么独特，以及我们对其他人如何感知世界做了很多假设。通常这是基于我们自己的经验，而且我们在文化上有很多共同点。所以我们共同的经验是我们如何听东西，如何尝东西，我们知道
about other people's taste. They do like this flavor. They don't like that flavor. They hate strawberries, coriander tastes like soaked to them. These are things that we talk about. and then we have these things that we don't talk about because they really come up in conversation much and that we make assumptions about.
关于其他人的口味。他们喜欢这种味道，不喜欢那种味道。他们讨厌草莓，香菜对他们来说尝起来像肥皂。这些是我们谈论的事情。然后我们有一些我们不谈论的事情，因为它们很少出现在对话中，而且我们对此做了假设。
And one of them, I didn't realize I was synesthetic until I was in my 20s, didn't even know there was a word for it. These days it's a lot easier to find these things out. But you also have it in terms of other neurodiversity, in terms of ADHD, autism, all across the spectrum. And then you get some really interesting ones, which are not addition of things, but the absence of things. And ophantasia is an interesting one
其中之一，我直到20多岁才知道自己有联觉，甚至不知道有这个词。如今，发现这些事情要容易得多。但你也会在其他神经多样性方面遇到这种情况，比如多动症（ADHD）、自闭症，涵盖整个谱系。然后你会遇到一些非常有趣的例子，它们不是事物的增加，而是事物的缺失。心盲症（Aphantasia）就是一个有趣的例子，
because it's basically the absence of a mind's eye that you don't have a visualization of what you're reading, perhaps. You know, when you're reading a book, do you visualize the characters? And there is a, it turns out, that not everybody does. And this is a surprise to many people. In fact, the term itself, A Fantasia, is only really about 10 years old or so, even though people started becoming aware of it before that. And many people who have it that don't have a mind's eye,
因为它基本上是“心眼”的缺失，即你在阅读时可能没有视觉化呈现。你知道，当你读一本书时，你会把角色视觉化吗？事实证明，并非每个人都会这样做。这对许多人来说是一个惊喜。事实上，这个术语本身，“心盲症”，大约只有10年的历史，尽管人们在此之前就开始意识到它了。许多患有此症的人，没有心眼，
First of all, when somebody makes a film of their favorite book, and other people are complaining, oh, you know, it doesn't look how I expected. And they're going like, well, I didn't expect it to look like anything. But what's interesting is that in their life, they have assumed that everybody's use of visual language with respect to memory is figurative. And so they make that assumption. They don't actually think, oh, that's metaphorical. They're figuratively speaking as if.
首先，当有人把他们最喜欢的书拍成电影时，其他人会抱怨说，哦，它看起来和我预想的不一样。而他们会说，好吧，我根本没预想它看起来是什么样。但有趣的是，在他们的生活中，他们一直认为每个人在记忆中使用视觉语言都是比喻性的。所以他们做了那个假设。他们并没有真正认为，哦，那是隐喻。他们只是在比喻性地说话，好像是那样。
But actually, they're actually having a very different experience. They are genuinely not seeing anything. their memory and their perception, their imagination is organized fundamentally differently. And there's a whole sliding scale. It's not an on-off thing. As developers, we like to think in terms of ones and zeros, no, it's not like that at all. You get hyperphantasia at the other end of the scale, which is just like your memory, how you imagine things is super vivid, even beyond reality. And so there's this kind of idea of there's a whole sensory experience that some people have got more of, and other people are absolutely missing, which, you know, whenever you're
但实际上，他们有着非常不同的体验。他们确实什么也看不见。他们的记忆、感知和想象力的组织方式有着根本的不同。而且这有一个完整的滑动量表。这不是一个非黑即白的事情。作为开发者，我们喜欢用1和0来思考，不，根本不是那样。在量表的另一端，你会得到超心像（Hyperphantasia），即你的记忆，你想象事物的方式极其生动，甚至超越了现实。所以有一种想法是，有些人拥有更多的感官体验，而另一些人则完全缺失，你知道，每当你
in a conversation where somebody has or has not got one of these things, there's always this kind of look of disbelief or, you know, what does that feel like? And it's just like what it feels like being is one of those things. But yeah, it's an interesting one, Aphantasia. Yeah, we've talked about this now a couple times over the last week. And I had not, I didn't know the word Afantasia. And you, we'll link it in the show notes. You sent me a podcast.
在一段对话中，有人拥有或没有这些东西之一，总是会出现那种难以置信的表情，或者，你知道，那是什么感觉？这就像“存在”本身就是其中之一。但是的，这是一个有趣的现象，心盲症。是的，过去一周我们已经讨论过几次了。我以前不知道“心盲症”这个词。你，我们会在节目说明中链接它。你发给我一个播客。
I think it was, was it Rutherford and Fry? Yep. Or is it, I got that backwards. Anyways, it's a very interesting conversation. And, yeah, the idea that you don't have a visual, in your head. Like, I took a quiz online. It said that I had hyperfantasia, but I'm a little, I'm a little skeptical. It was on some, like, you know, takea quiz.org. So I, because I, I don't have the vividness, but I definitely, you know, I talk with my wife all the time about this is that, like, my
我想是卢瑟福和弗莱（Rutherford and Fry）的？是的。或者是我记反了。总之，这是一个非常有趣的对话。而且，是的，你脑子里没有视觉图像的想法。就像，我在网上做了一个测试。它说我有超心像，但我有点怀疑。它是在某个类似“takea quiz.org”的网站上。所以我，因为我没有那种生动感，但我绝对，你知道，我经常和我的妻子谈论这个，就像，我的
ability to go back and replay, like, a run in my head from, like, you know, 10 years ago that I used to do, like, on a, you know, every second day. Like, I can, there's a run that I used to do in China when I lived in Hongzhou. I can still visualize, like, all the turns. It's not, like, more than reality but like when I ask her oh like can't don't you remember we just went on a drive and she's like I have no idea and then the same thing you mentioned textures we've always talked about how we think that our pallets are on like a different experience level because a lot of stuff I think her distribution or range it's like ah everything's kind of good where I'm just like if there's cheese and something it is uh I can I could smell it on the the speaker dinner we had
回到过去并在脑海中重播的能力，比如10年前我曾经做过的事情，比如每隔一天做一次。就像，我在中国住在杭州时曾经跑过的一条路线。我仍然可以视觉化所有的转弯。它不是比现实更生动，但当我问她，“哦，你不记得我们刚开车去过那里吗？”她说，“我完全没印象。”然后你提到的质地，我们一直谈论我们认为我们的味觉处于不同的体验水平，因为很多东西，我认为她的分布或范围是，啊，什么都还行，而我只是，如果里面有奶酪，我能闻到它。在那个演讲者晚餐上，我们
the other night and they had the risotto that they put down and I could before they even put it on the table, I could smell that there was cheese. Anyways, I just think it's very interesting, because how often, except for this past week, are you ever really talking about the difference or the delta between you and your peers or your friends or your partners, how you experience the world? Because kind of people, they say, oh, you're a bit odd for not liking cheese at the, you know, the extremity that you know. It's like, well, if you could feel the reaction of like what it's, it's, I mean, it doesn't
那天晚上，他们端上了烩饭，在他们把它放在桌子上之前，我就能闻到里面有奶酪。总之，我只是觉得这非常有趣，因为除了过去这一周，你多久会真正谈论你与同龄人、朋友或伴侣之间的差异或差距，即你是如何体验世界的？因为人们会说，哦，你因为不喜欢奶酪而有点古怪。这就像，好吧，如果你能感受到那种反应，那似乎并不那么不合理。但我想对其他人来说，他们不喜欢某样东西，就像，啊，我只是，我宁愿不吃，但我可以吃。总之，你说过你和你的儿子讨论过这些事情，这正是启发所在。显然，你在20多岁时发现了联觉，但与你儿子交谈。总之，我不确定你是否想补充什么，但我只是觉得这是一个如此根本的问题，即我们感知世界的方式。
seem that unreasonable. But I think for other people, they don't like something. It's like, ah, I just, I kind of prefer not to, but I can eat it. Anyways, and you said you've had discussions with your son about this stuff, and that's kind of what's illuminated. Obviously, you discovered this in your 20s with a synesthesia, but talking to your son. Anyways, it's, I'm not sure if you want to add, like, anything, but I just think it's such a fundamental, like, the way we perceive the world.
我会补充说，我在几年前的一次演讲中用过这个，你见过那个，你知道，“你是什么意思？你是什么意思？哦，哦，哦，你是什么？”在那里，我探讨了这样一种想法，即当我们交流时，特别是在软件领域，我们总是在交流，我们试图构建东西，我们试图传达我们的意思，有些事情我们通常能做对，有些事情我们知道我们经常会绊倒，因此需要澄清，我们对此有所了解。然后还有一些我们甚至不知道我们在做假设的事情，即它是不同的。你知道，我在一次演讲中用了这个，基本上是说，这里有一个关于误解的滑动量表，但也包括从共享经验到非共享经验。当你有一种特定的体验时，无论是由于你拥有某种增强的东西、某种添加的东西还是某种被移除的东西，这确实很难，那是什么感觉？这真的很难描述，但我们通常没有共同的对话，所以我们不知道，我们对其他人做了假设。我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，就像，你知道，仔细倾听，仔细倾听，仔细观察。
I will add that I used that in a talk a few years ago, one that you've seen that, you know, what do you mean? What do you mean? Oh, oh, oh, what do you? where I kind of explored this idea of like some things there are common myths that when we communicate and certainly in the world of software we're always communicating we're trying to build stuff we're trying to communicate what we mean and there's some things that we kind of typically get right there's things that we know we often stumble over and therefore need to clarify we're kind of
我们想做的很多事情是更仔细的观察，如果你愿意的话。我的意思是，这让我想到，因为我是一个机器人，你知道，我生命中的某个时刻必须学习同理心，因为它对我来说并不自然。我读了几本不同的书，都很糟糕。它们总是有一个基本的总结，就像，你知道，同理心就是设身处地为他人着想。很长一段时间以来，我从来没有真正理解这一点。我想，我可以设身处地为他们着想。
aware of this and then there's stuff we don't even know we're assuming that is different and you know I use this in a talk basically saying here is this sliding scale of you know misunderstanding but also shared experience to unshared experience that is genuinely hard when you have a particular experience either because you have something heightened something added or something removed what does that feel like and it's really difficult to describe but we often don't have a shared conversation so we don't know we make assumptions about other people and that's and I think that's a really interesting one that it's just like you know listen carefully listen carefully watch carefully.
这没什么大不了的。就像，你为什么难过？但后来我听到一句名言，同理心实际上并不是设身处地为他人着想，而是理解那个人在他们的处境中是什么感觉。因为当你设身处地为他人着想时，你带入了你自己的生活经历，
It's a lot of what we want to do is much more careful observation, if you like. I mean, that made me just think, because the robot that I am, you know, I had to learn empathy at some point in my life because it didn't come natural to me. And I read a couple different books that were all terrible. And they always had their basic, you know, summary was like, you know, empathy is about putting yourself in someone else's shoes. And that's not, for the longest time, I never really got that. I was like, I can put myself in their shoes.
等等。所以你进入了他们的处境，然后现在你又变回了你自己。就像，好吧，我仍然认为这有点……但如果你真的想，那个人在他们的处境中是什么感觉？如果你没有生活经历或任何与他们正在经历的事情相近的东西，就很难产生同理心，
And it's like, yeah, it's not a big deal. Like, well, why are you upset? but then I heard a quote that was empathy is not actually putting yourself in someone else's shoes it's understanding what it's like for that person to be in their shoes because when you put yourself in someone else's shoes you bring your own lived experiences
因为你现在必须基本上想象他们带着他们的历史等等是什么感觉。如果你经历过类似的事情，这可能是一件非常困难的事情，你越接近经历过那种事情，就越容易，就像，哦，你知道，我经历过非常相似的事情。我完全能产生同理心，你知道，因为我经历过。但如果你没有，总之，这是一个，另一个有趣的例子，关于经验和感知，这都是，呃，如果我们能找到一种方法进行更多这样的对话，我们所有人可能都会生活在一个更健康、更好的世界里。总之，还有要学习的，或者我学到的，
and whatnot and so you go in their shoes and then now you're just you again and it's like well I know I still think it's kind of but if you actually think well what is it like for that person to be in their shoes and if you don't have a lived experience or anything that's remotely close to what they're going through it is very hard to empathize
因为当我听那个播客时，他们谈到了心盲症，但他们也谈到了缺乏内心独白。我就想，为什么，联觉有一个词，但没有词。确实有一个词，叫“内言缺失症”（Anendophasia）。内言缺失症，就是那个。
because you now have to basically imagine what it is like for them with their, like, history and whatnot. And that is a, that can be a very difficult thing if you have, you know, the closer you are to having been through that, the much easier, it's like, oh, you know, I've gone through something very similar. I completely empathize, you know, because I've been through it. But if you haven't, anyways, it's a, another interesting, like, how experiences and perception, it's all, uh, probably, we would all be living in a healthier, better world if we could find a way to have more of these conversations. and anyways, and also to be learned, or I learned,
你怎么发音？我打算用“an endopphasia”，但可能不同。所以如果有任何神经学家或精神科医生在听，请告诉我们。但是的，另一个，我过去常和我爸爸谈论这个，因为他小时候是个狂热的读者，读完了罗伯特·海因莱因（Robert Heinlein）
because when I was listening to that podcast, they talk about Afantasia, but then they also talk about a lack of an inner monologue. And I was like, well, why is there, there's a word for synesthesia, but there's no word. There is a word for it, and it's anendophagia. Anendiphasia, that's it.
和所有的科幻小说，阿西莫夫等等。我记得他说他和一个，我不记得是老师还是同学，在他高中时。他说他一生中大部分时间都活在自己的脑子里，一直在说话。你知道，就像那样，在你的内心独白中，你说话，你交谈最多的人
And how do you pronounce it? I'm going to go with an endopphasia, but it could be different. So if there are any neurologists or psychiatrists who are listening in, just let us know. But yeah, another, I used to talk to my dad about that because he was a massive reader as a kid and consumed all of Robert Heimline
就是你脑子里的那个声音。他说他遇到了一个人，说，哦，那听起来有点疯狂。就像，我脑子里没有声音。他当时就想，什么？人们脑子里没有声音吗？是的，所以这是一个普遍的事情，你可能遇到过这个梗。有一张摩根·弗里曼（Morgan Freeman）的照片，然后有一句引语，你在脑子里听到他在读它。
and all the sci-fi and Asimov, et cetera. And I remember he said he talked to a, I can't remember he was a teacher or a peer when he was in high school. And he said he lived most of his life like inside of his head just talking. You know, it's like that, in your monologue, you talk, the person you talk to the most
摩根·弗里曼有一个非常独特的声音。重点是，这并不适用于所有人。是的。是的，但当，如果某人，那个概念，当你收到你认识的人的电子邮件时，你听到的声音，与来自匿名且你不认识的人的电子邮件不同，因为你可以听到他们的声音在说它。事实证明，这并不适用于所有人。更重要的是，这对某些人来说比对其他人更真实。
is that voice inside your head. And he said he met someone and said, oh, that kind of sounds crazy. Like, I don't have a voice in my name. He was like, what? Do people not have voices in their head? Yeah, so there is this common thing, and you probably come across this meme. There is this, you know, picture of Morgan Freeman, and then there is a quote, and you are hearing him in your head, reading it.
是的，我不知道有多少听众，因为我们，我是说，在最初的一两个月里，我想通常有大约4000到5000人收听。从统计学上讲，肯定有很多人对此产生共鸣。但我不知道有多少人是第一次听到这个，你知道吗？就像，我想那些有联觉、心盲症的人，甚至还有一个术语
And Morgan Freeman has a very distinctive voice. And the whole point there is that that is not true for everyone. Yeah. Yeah, but when, if somebody, and that notion, when you have an email from somebody that you know, you hear, it's different from an email from somebody who is anonymous and unknown to you, because you can hear their voice saying it. It turns out that is not true for everybody. And more importantly, it's more true for some people than others.
关于你第一次听到时体验不同质地的方式，并觉得，等等，什么？就像，你知道，我并不孤单，或者我没有意识到人们在脑子里看到图片，或者他们脑子里有声音？总之，有趣的思考素材。
Yeah, and I wonder to how many listeners, because we, I mean, it's over the first month or two, I think there's usually about 4,000 to 5,000 people to listen. There's got to be, just statistically speaking, a number of folks that are resonating with this. I wonder how many, though, are hearing it for the first time, you know? Like, I imagine of the people that have synesthesia, infantasia, and then there's even a term
希望这能引起一些讨论，你知道，去和你的同事、伴侣或家人谈谈，是的，让世界变得更美好。我们录了多少分钟了？哦，我们才录了一半，太完美了。让我们转向，因为我很想谈谈，我们之后会谈谈Al的演讲。但我没有看凯夫林最近的第二次演讲，对吧？
for the way you experience different textures for the first time listening and being like, wait, what? Like, you know, I'm not alone or like I didn't realize that people are seeing, you know, pictures in their head or do they have a voice inside their head? Anyways, interesting food for thought.
从技术上讲，这是你最近的吗？你最近第一次做的演讲是什么？是哥本哈根的那场吗？这有点难算，因为……我想是哥本哈根的那场。是的，我想是哥本哈根的那场。我在想。但那场肯定是新的。
Hopefully this causes some discussions, you know, go and talk to your coworkers or your partner or your family and, yeah, make the world a better place. How many minutes were at? Oh, we're only halfway, so perfect. Let's pivot to, because I'm eager to talk about, we'll talk a bit about the Al talk afterwards. But so I did not see Kevlin's second most recent, right?
没有之前的版本，之后也没有版本。那是10月初。是的。所以是10月初，没有上YouTube。我观看的时候，是在飞机上，当我们去布里斯班的路上，也就是几天前。当我从YouTube下载它在飞机上观看时，它说它是三周前发布的。
Technically, is it your more recent? What's the talk that you gave for the first time most recently? Was it the Copenhagen one? That's a little bit of hard math to do because... I think it is the Copenhagen. Yeah, I think it is the Copenhagen one. I'm trying to think. But certainly that one was new.
所以，我想它是在11月下旬发布的。那时我正在度蜜月，我想。所以我通常YouTube非常擅长向我推荐凯夫林的所有演讲，即使只有三次观看，它也知道，这是凯夫林的演讲。康纳想看这个。所以我很震惊地听到你有一个演讲上线了，而我还没看过。而且，我猜标题是《曾经的未来》（The Future That Was）？
There was no previous version of it, and there has been no version since. and that was the beginning of October. Yes. So it was beginning of October and didn't hit YouTube. It said when I watched it, which was on the plane, when we were on their way to Brisbane, so a couple days ago. And when I downloaded it from YouTube to watch it on the plane, it said it had dropped three weeks ago.
接近了。接近了。《未来的样子》（The way the future was）。《未来的样子》。我会把麦克风交给你，是的，请随意为听众剧透。我们会在节目说明中链接它，正如我们提到的。但告诉他们这个演讲是关于什么的。然后我们会在你告诉听众之后聊聊。好的。所以这是我和ThoughtWorks的詹姆斯·刘易斯（James Lewis）共同做的演讲。我们大概在过去三年里一直想一起做一个演讲。我大约三年前采访过詹姆斯。我们只是沉迷于各种各样的东西。之后，我们也继续交谈。我在各种会议和机场也这样做过，有时谈论科幻小说，有时谈论政治，有时谈论“未来的样子”，指的是我们注意到的这种差异。我们是同一代人。这种概念，它开始在在线会议中发生。我们都是Go To大会的程序委员会成员。在每次在线会议期间，詹姆斯和我有时会谈论，哦，是的，是的，这是20世纪70年代或80年代想象的东西。人们会把这个投射到未来。我们也开始谈论这种想法，即定性上是我几年前注意到的。它最初是几年前被我大儿子偶然引起我注意的。
So it, I think, was released sometime late November. And I was on my honeymoon then, I think. So I usually YouTube, very good at recommending me all of Kevlin's talks, even when there's like three views on it, It knows, it's a Kevlin talk. Connor wants to watch this. And so I was shocked to hear that there was a talk of yours that had come online and I hadn't seen it. And actually, I'm going to guess the title, The Future That Was?
我给他看了几本我小时候读的书。这些书出版于70年代末。他当时和我那时差不多大，所以我猜他大约10、11岁。这些是关于未来的书。事实证明我有几本。这些书很受欢迎。但这些特定的书，最近被重新汇编并重新发布了《Usborn未来之书》。这是一件很棒的重新包装作品，因为他们所做的是
Close. Close. The way the future was. The way the future was. And I'll hand the mic to you and, yeah, feel free to spoil it for the listener. We'll link it in the show notes, as we mentioned. But tell them what this talk was about. And then we'll chat a little bit about after you've told the listener. Yeah. So this was a talk I did jointly with James Lewis from ThoughtWorks. We've been angling to do a talk together for probably the last three years. I did an interview with James about three years ago. And we just kind of nerded out and a whole bunch of stuff. And afterwards, we also continued talking. And I have done so in various conferences and airports, sometimes about science fiction, sometimes about politics, sometimes about the way the future was in the sense of this difference that we'd
他们没有改变原文。他们把原来的三卷薄书合为一卷，并说《Usborn未来之书》，基本上给它加了一个标语。这就是70年代眼中的21世纪。一种重新包装材料的可爱方式，但也让我拥有了一个目前不会散架的版本。那是几年前圣诞节我收到的礼物。但当我儿子还小的时候，他看了这些书，他简直完全着迷了。他只是看着这个，因为为什么我们现在没有这样的东西了？我突然想到，哦，这很有趣。
we'd noticed we're kind of similar generation. And there's this notion, it started happening in terms of online meeting. We were both program committee members of the go-to conference. And during each online meeting, James and I would sometimes end up talking about, oh, yeah, yeah, and this was an imagined thing back in the 1970s or 80s. People would project this into the future. And we also started talking about this idea that qualitatively is something that I'd noticed. a few years ago, it was first brought to my attention accidentally by my older son.
这是一个好问题。如果你愿意的话，这个演讲是对那个问题的回应。我是说，我向我儿子道歉。这个回应迟到了近十五年。但重点是，它在探索那个问题。为什么会这样？现在有什么不同，因为有一个标准的说法，你知道，老头子说，是的，它不像过去那样了，诸如此类。所以我检查了一下，那只是我
I showed him a couple of books that I read as a kid. And these books were published in the late 70s. And he was about the same age as I was then, so I guess he was around 10, 11. And these are books of the future. It turns out I have a few of these. These are quite popular. But these particular ones, they got recompiled recently and re-released the Usborn Book of the Future. It's a lovely piece of repackaging because what they've done
还是一个客观事实？事实证明，这似乎更像是一个客观事实。不仅仅是我儿子注意到那个领域书籍的缺失。有一些书出版了，但我们这样说吧。它们不一样，没有我们过去拥有的那种乐观情绪或普遍性。它们更多的是，我觉得这在某种程度上是一种天真的乐观。但也有一个想法，可以追溯到，我们通常在科幻小说中发现它，但肯定是在第二次世界大战后，一个想法，一个非常强烈的技术乐观主义想法。技术乐观主义依然存在，但我想说，它曾经更像是一种默认设定。
is they haven't changed the original text. They've taken the original three slender volumes, put them in one and said the Usborn Book of the Future, just basically given it a tagline. This is how the 21st century look from the 1970s. A lovely way of repackaging the material, but also allowing me to have a version that is currently not falling apart. And I got given that for Christmas, a couple Christmas is back. But when my son was younger, he looked at these books, and he was just like absolutely fascinated. He was just looking at this, because why don't we have anything like this now? And I suddenly thought, oh, that's kind of interesting.
那是一种认为未来意味着进步的观念。21世纪在某种程度上——如果我们能克服可能自我毁灭这一小问题的话——如果我们能跨过那道坎，那么21世纪，也许我们就能成熟起来。这就像是一种《星际迷航》式的宇宙。就像我们达到了某个临界点，所有的潜能都被释放，所有的可能性都展现出来。
That's a good question. And if you like, this talk was a response to that question. I mean, I apologize to my son. The response is nearly a decade and a half late. But the point there was, it's exploring that question. Why is this the case? so different about now, because there is the standard thing, you know, old man going like, yeah, it's not the way it used to be and all this kind of stuff. So I check, is that just me
这不仅仅是指飞行汽车之类的东西，它在思考乌托邦以及类似方向时要深刻得多。在70年代和80年代，确实存在一种这样的感觉——我无法代表60年代，因为我当时并没有真正参与其中，只是
or is it an objective thing? And it turns out that it seems to be more of an objective thing. And it's not just my son noticing an absence of books in that space. There are a few books that are published, but let's put it this way. They are not the same, not with the same kind of like optimism or prevalence that we used to have. They were much more, there was a, I feel like It's a naive optimism at one level. But there was also an idea that goes back, typically we find it within science fiction, but certainly post-second World War, an idea, a very strong idea of techno-optimism. Techno-automism still exists, but I want to say that it was more of a default.
模糊地存在着——但50年代、60年代，你知道，杰森一家对未来的展望，你可以在当时的科幻小说中看到这一点。现在，这种情况持续着，然后90年代发生了。柏林墙倒塌了。冷战结束了。我们做到了。我们，我们成熟了。这一切都很好。有一个整体的想法，这实际上是我在演讲中引用的达伦·阿罗诺夫斯基（Darren Aronofsky）的话。就像90年代，你知道，那是一个美妙的时期，我们没有种族毁灭的核威胁。最糟糕的政治丑闻是比尔·克林顿有婚外情。
It was the idea that the future means progress. The 21st century is somehow, if we can just get past this small issue of maybe wiping ourselves out, if we can get past that then the 21st century maybe we grow up it's a kind of a Star Trek universe is like we get to a point and all of the potential is unleashed all of these possibilities
你知道，就是那样。21世纪充满了可能性。我们到了。我们快要得到了。我们快要得到了。是的，我们就在边缘。所有好的东西都说，哦，网络。所以网络，你知道，你在这么多科幻小说中看到的在线网络，这一切都很好。你知道，只是有一种贫富差距的感觉。那不会是个问题。未来将充满各种各样的可能性。总之，21世纪到了，显然我们并没有处于那种状态。所以，事情改变了。你可以把它放在一种9/11后的时代视角中。有很多不同的事情。
and this is not just sort of saying flying cars and stuff like that it's much deeper in terms of like thinking about utopias and along those lines and there was genuinely a sense in the 70s and 80s I can't speak for the 60s I was not really there only
但人们的视角发生了质的变化。同样，检查各个年龄段，这里确实存在差异。在2025年，当我们展望2050年时，它感觉不一样，它没有那种在1975年展望2000年的感觉。我们确实有，让我们非常清楚，我们有一些非常酷的东西，实际上在演讲中我们将演讲分成了几个部分，未来的样子，然后是演讲的标题，然后是未来的现状，当我们比较时，这稍微令人沮丧，以及未来是如何形成的，我们实际上观察了事物的机制，
vaguely present but 50s 60s, you know, the jets and view of the future, and you just see it in the science fiction of the time. Now, that continued, and then the 90s happened. The Berlin Wall came down. The Cold War was over. We've done it. We've, we've grown up. This is all good. And there's this whole idea, this is actually quote in the talk that I used, Darren Aronofsky. It's just like the 90s, you know, it was just like wonderful period where we didn't have the, threat of nuclear destruction of the whole race. The worst political scandal was Bill Clinton having an affair.
这更有趣，然后我们基本上以未来可能的样子结束，如果你愿意的话，这是一个行动呼吁，但这并不是保证。我们什么都不能保证。所以，顺便说一句，在这个意义上有很多剧透。但有一个比较，在20世纪70年代，有一种观点，像杰拉德·奥尼尔（Gerard O'Neill）这样的人提出了诸如“嘿，我们可以在太空中拥有城市”的想法。他有一个非常独特的观点，很多意象对于任何看过科幻电影的人来说都很熟悉。这些已经进入了主流媒体，巨大的轨道结构。这些已经进入了主流媒体。但他有一个非常独特的愿景，而且是一个非常
You know, that was it. And it was just like the 21st century was filled with possibility. We've arrived. We're about to get it. We're about to get it. Yeah, we are on the edge. All the good stuff said, oh, the web. So the network, you know, the online network you saw referred to in so much science
乌托邦式的愿景。然后我们有了像2013年的《极乐空间》（Elysium）这样的电影，这是一幅更黑暗、更黑暗的图景。我们有美丽的轨道，但它只属于最顶层的百分之几。它是终极的封闭式社区。它是同样的物理结构。然而，政治和财富差距以及随之而来的言外之意非常有趣。我最近在2025年重看了《极乐空间》，这与2013年观看时的体验非常不同。在那类2016年后的世界里，有很多事情让人觉得，哦天哪，这不是我们所希望的未来。仍然有很多事情是可能的，但当我们审视这些可能性时，这就是我们开始描绘乐观图景的地方，大多数事情发生不是因为你试图去制造它们。换句话说，视频电话，人们花了20世纪的大部分时间试图制造视频电话，但它从未流行起来。事实证明，视频电话，当它发生时，它发生并不是因为人们试图创造视频电话。它是偶然的。它依赖于其他技术。它有一种来自消息平台的普遍性。换句话说，它不是来自，你知道，在20世纪，是像AT&T这样的人，他们正在探索视频电话。当然他们会这样做，因为他们是一家电信公司。但视频电话并不是来自电信公司。它是通过一种无处不在的通信背板的后门进来的，足够的带宽。事实上，有时人们想扩展他们的消息传递，无论是MSN Messenger还是最近的WhatsApp，你注意到所有这些都有一个辅助的视频功能。它只是被附加在上面，因为你可以拥有它。这就是重点。它使它变得不可避免。我们看到了这一点，所以我们看到了那种想法，
fiction, this is all good. You know, there was just a sense of wealth disparity. That's not going to be a problem. The future is going to be filled with all these kinds of possibilities. Anyway, 21st century arrived and that apparently is not where we're at. And so therefore, things changed. You can put it in a kind of post-9-11 era kind of view. There's lots of different things.
即获得某些技术的途径不是通过瞄准技术本身，而是通过观察它们建立在什么基础之上。这给出了一个非常、非常不同的图景。我们有很多关于汽车的对话。人们喜欢使用汽车隐喻。每个人都关注汽车的技术。但汽车最大的福音是柏油路。
But there was something qualitatively different about people's perspectives. And again, checking through age groups that there is a difference here. In 2025, when we look at 2050, it doesn't feel, it doesn't. doesn't have the same feeling as being in 1975 looking at 2000 we do have a we let's let's be very clear we have some really cool stuff and actually in the talk we break the talk down into a number of sections the way the future was and then the title of the talk and then the way the future it is which is slightly more depressing when we compare it and the way the future came to be where we actually look at what's the mechanics of
没有它，现代汽车就不会像现在这样。它不会有它的普遍性，不会看起来像它们那样。事实证明，是道路造就了汽车。当然，汽车是，就像我的设备必须有一个摄像头我才能有视频体验一样。你必须有一辆车才能有驾驶体验，但实际上它社会普及的最大贡献者是道路以及我们如何思考道路和组织道路。
stuff and that's a little more interesting and the way and then we basically end with the way the future could be, you know, if you like, a call to action, but it's not a guarantee. We're not guaranteed of anything. So, by the way, plenty of spoilers here in this sense. But there is a comparative thing that in the 1970s there was a view, people like Gerard O'Neill were putting forward the idea of like, hey, we can have cities in space. And he had a very particular view, and a lot of the imagery will be familiar to anybody who's watch science fiction films. These have made their way in, vast orbital structures. These made their way into mainstream media. But he had a very particular vision, and it was a very
因此，作为技术专家，诀窍在于我们有时瞄准得太高，然后对采用的失败感到失望，结果十年后当某种其他技术、某种其他平台级的东西或某种变得隐藏但无处不在的东西成为常态时，才看到它发生。所以詹姆斯和我探讨了许多这些事情。我们谈论能源分配。
utopian one. And then we get films like 2013's Elysium, which is a much darker, darker picture. We have the beautiful orbital, but it's only for the top fraction of a percent. It is the kind of the ultimate gated community. And it is the same physical structure. And yet the political and wealth disparity and the overtones that go with it are quite interesting. And I recently re-watched Elysium in 2025, and it's a very different experience to watching it in 2013. In that kind of post-2016 world, there's a lot that's been a lot of things that are kind of like, oh dear, this is not the future we had hoped for. There's still a lot of things that are possible, but when we look at the possibilities, this is where we start painting a picture
我们谈论元宇宙的失败。这是一种复古未来主义的想法。就像人们在80年代和90年代初认为未来可能的样子。但我们到达了一个不同版本的网络。我们的体验有着根本的不同。我不想为了买东西而走过一个虚拟购物中心。
of optimism is that most things happen not because you try to make them. In other words, the video phone, people spent the better part of the 20th century trying to make video phones and it never took off. And it turns out the video phone, when it happened, it happened just not because people were trying to create a video phone. It was incidental. It relied on other technologies. It had a prevalence that came from messaging platforms. In other words, it was not from the, you know, in the 20th century, it was people like AT&T, they were kind of exploring video phones. And of course they would because they're a telecommunications company. But the video phone did not come from the telecoms companies. It came through the kind of the back door of like
那是一种笨拙、缓慢的体验。当我只需敲击几下键盘就能立即订购东西时，我为什么要那样做呢？我们最终得到了一个目录隐喻。所以，你知道，在线购物是目录隐喻的延伸。它不是购物中心体验的延伸。我们已经做出了那个决定。
a communications backplane that was ubiquitous, sufficient bandwidth. The fact that sometimes people wanted to extend their messaging, whether that was a MS messenger or whether that was more recently WhatsApp, you notice that all of these have a secondary video facility. It's just like tacked on because you could have it. And that's the whole point. It made it inevitable. And we see that, so we see that kind of idea
一个无处不在的通信背板，带宽充足。事实上，有时人们想要扩展他们的消息传递功能，无论是MS Messenger还是最近的WhatsApp，你会注意到所有这些都有辅助视频功能。这就像是附加的，因为你可以拥有它。这就是重点所在。这使得它不可避免。我们看到了这一点，所以我们看到了那种想法
that the way to get certain technologies is not by targeting the technologies, but by looking at what they are built on. And that gives a very, very different picture. We have a lot of conversations about the car. People love using car metaphors. And everybody focuses on the technology of the car. But the biggest boon to the car was the tarmacs road.
即获得某些技术的途径不是针对技术本身，而是着眼于它们建立的基础。这提供了一个非常非常不同的图景。我们有很多关于汽车的对话。人们喜欢使用汽车隐喻。每个人都关注汽车的技术。但对汽车最大的推动力是柏油路。
Without that, the modern car would not look like it does. It would not have its ubiquity, would not look like they do. It turns out that it was the road that made the car. Of course, the car was, just like my devices have to have a camera for me to have a video experience. You have to have a car to have a driving experience, but actually the biggest contributor to its social uptake is the road and how we think about roads and how we organise roads.
没有它，现代汽车就不会是现在的样子。它不会有现在的普及度，也不会看起来像现在这样。事实证明，是道路造就了汽车。当然，汽车确实存在，就像我的设备必须有摄像头我才能有视频体验一样。你必须有一辆车才能有驾驶体验，但实际上对其社会普及贡献最大的是道路，以及我们如何思考道路和组织道路。
And so therefore, as technologists, the trick is we kind of keep aiming sometimes a little bit too high and then being disappointed by the failure of adoption, only to see it happen a decade later when some other technology, some other platform-level thing or something that becomes hidden but ubiquitous becomes normal. So James and I kind of explore a number of these things. We talk in terms of energy distribution.
因此，作为技术专家，诀窍在于我们有时目标定得太高，然后对采用失败感到失望，结果十年后当其他技术、其他平台级的东西或某种变得隐蔽但无处不在的东西成为常态时，才看到它发生。所以詹姆斯和我探讨了其中的一些事情。我们从能源分配的角度来谈。
We talk about the failure of the metaverse. It's a kind of retro-futurist idea. It's like what people thought the future might look like in the 1980s and the early 90s. But we arrived at a different version of the web. Our experience is fundamentally different. I don't want to be walking through a virtual shopping mall in order to buy stuff.
我们谈论元宇宙的失败。这是一种复古未来主义的想法。就像人们在20世纪80年代和90年代初认为未来可能的样子。但我们最终得到了一个不同版本的网络。我们的体验从根本上是不同的。我不想为了买东西而走过虚拟购物中心。
That's a janky, slow experience. Why would I want to do that when with a flick of a couple of keystrokes I can order stuff immediately? We ended up with a catalogue metaphor. So, you know, online shopping is an extension of the catalogue metaphor. It is not an extension of the shopping mall experience. And we've already made that decision.
那是一种笨拙、缓慢的体验。当我只需敲击几下键盘就能立即订购商品时，我为什么要那样做呢？我们最终采用了目录隐喻。所以，你知道，在线购物是目录隐喻的延伸。它不是购物中心体验的延伸。我们已经做出了那个决定。
And so there's this interesting thing that there's a future that was a future path not taken. So we kind of talk a little bit about that. But that notion of the optimism, we stored a lot of hope up. We lived under a particular, well, we lived under a particular shadow of the Atomot. We also had post-Second World War optimism.
所以有一件很有趣的事情，那就是存在一个我们没有选择的未来路径。我们稍微讨论了一下这一点。但关于乐观主义的那个概念，我们积攒了太多的希望。我们生活在某种特定的阴影下，嗯，我们生活在原子时代的特定阴影下。我们也拥有二战后的乐观主义。
We talk a little bit more about other culture perspectives in the talk as well. But there is this idea that in the 21st century, something else has happened. We've achieved a dominance. the tech bro dominance is it turns out that they're not all in it for the good things they're not in it for the good of humanity and it turns out that with great power
我们在演讲中也讨论了其他文化视角。但有一种观点认为，在21世纪，发生了一些别的事情。我们实现了一种统治。事实证明，科技兄弟们的统治并非全是为了好事，他们并非为了人类的利益，而且事实证明，拥有巨大的权力，
you can exercise any kind of lack of responsibility you want and that becomes part of the issue but at the same time that's also our call to action at the end of the talk we're kind of like you know what this could be different we have an immense amount of power collectively most of the technologies
你可以行使任何你想要的极度不负责任的行为，这成了问题的一部分，但与此同时，这也是我们在演讲结束时的行动号召，我们就像是，你知道吗，这本可以不同，我们集体拥有巨大的力量，大多数技术
for solving real problems have not yet been put together but they are there they're waiting to be done so there is possibility there but yeah it was an interesting exploration but the bit I loved most about the talk in addition to doing the talk
解决现实问题的技术还没有被整合在一起，但它们就在那里，等待着被完成，所以那里存在可能性，但是的，这是一次有趣的探索，但我最喜欢演讲的部分，除了做演讲之外，
with getting the chance to do it with James having a really receptive audience answering the question that my son laid out was also it allows me to like do a non-code or software related talk so technically I'm now a futurologist. I could be completely wrong, but most futurologists are. So that does not discredit
有机会和詹姆斯一起做这件事，拥有一个非常乐于接受的听众，回答我儿子提出的问题，也让我能够做一场与代码或软件无关的演讲，所以从技术上讲，我现在是一名未来学家。我可能完全错了，但大多数未来学家都是如此。所以这并不能否定
me from that, but I can now put that on my CV. Yeah, I think the reason the talk came up was because we were talking about a conversation that had been had at the first instance in Melbourne. And I realized that I had accidentally become like the bad guy, like the tech bro. And I mean, I talk with Shima, my wife all the time, and that she always tells me that I'm a techno-optimist, transhumanist. And And then after this conversation, I went and talked with her, and she was like, you know about the Overton window. I was like, I've heard of it. Anyway, she sent me a diagram, and she's like, what you have to understand is, is you have, like, radical views that society is not ready to accept. What, the interesting part, though, is that you're basically kind of in your talk show that, like, it used to not be radical to be hopeful about this technology.
我的身份，但我现在可以把它写进我的简历里了。是的，我想这次演讲之所以出现，是因为我们在谈论第一次在墨尔本进行的对话。我意识到我无意中变成了坏人，就像那个科技兄弟。我的意思是，我一直和我的妻子希玛交谈，她总是告诉我我是一个技术乐观主义者、超人类主义者。然后在那次谈话之后，我去找她谈了谈，她说，你知道奥弗顿之窗吗？我说，我听说过。总之，她发给我一张图表，她说，你必须明白的是，你有那种社会还没有准备好接受的激进观点。不过，有趣的部分是，你在演讲中基本上展示了，比如，对这项技术抱有希望曾经并不激进。
But now because of the, you know, it's multifactorial, no, the political climate, you know, the wealth in a quality you know and it's like uh and i had to really think about it as like oh wow like uh saying that i want to chip in my wrist uh for all this you know future stuff people you know she and my wife she even said oh like you know that can be offensive to some people you know it's like you're trying to take the humanity out of and i was like that's not what i'm trying to do i just uh it's like the equivalent of you hovering cars and whatever for the future anyways i just think it's it's a it's a great talk people should watch and it leads to interesting discussions of like, you know, it's not just
但现在因为，你知道，这是多因素的，不，政治气候，你知道，财富不平等，你知道，就像，呃，我不得不认真思考它，就像，哦哇，就像，呃，说我想在手腕里植入芯片，为了所有这些，你知道，未来的东西，人们，你知道，她，我的妻子，她甚至说，哦，就像，你知道，这对某些人来说可能是冒犯的，你知道，就像你试图剥夺人性，而我说，那不是我想做的，我只是，呃，这就像你为未来准备的悬浮汽车之类的东西，总之，我只是认为这是一个很棒的演讲，人们应该看看，它引出了有趣的讨论，比如，你知道，这不仅仅是
Elysium, which is a fantastic film, but like, I love anything adjacent to that. Like, you know, Altered Carbans, a TV show based on a book. I've read the first book. The books are, even the show, I think, it's like PG-18 or R, so if you, we got young listeners, wait a few years until you're in university.
《极乐空间》，那是一部很棒的电影，但我喜欢任何与之相关的东西。比如，你知道，《碳变》，一部根据书改编的电视剧。我读过第一本书。这些书，甚至这部剧，我认为，它是PG-18或R级的，所以如果你，我们有年轻的听众，等几年直到你上大学。
But, you know, like Black Mirror. And to be honest, a lot of the kind of future-based shows are dystopic. You know, Alien, Sean Pair, a recent guest. He was talking about alien and how they have the five, which are, it's a post-government society where five corporations govern the world, you know, not out of the realm of anyway. So it's interesting, though, that there
但是，你知道，比如《黑镜》。老实说，很多基于未来的节目都是反乌托邦的。你知道，肖恩·佩尔，最近的一位嘉宾。他在谈论《异形》以及他们如何拥有那五家公司，这是一个后政府社会，由五家公司统治世界，你知道，这并非完全不可能。所以，有趣的是，
aren't, there are way more dystopic kind of future TV shows versus like the Jetsons. We've got the vacuum cleaner robot. It's very interesting. I'm not sure, also, too, if listeners have recommendations of anything adjacent to Elysium, altered carbon, black mirror, any of that's, I love that stuff, I'm always looking. Pantheon, I guess Pantheon. I guess Pantheon, and anime, depending on how that was recommended by Joao a past guest on the pod, or not this pod, but a raycast. That's kind of not fully dystopic. It's about becoming
并没有，相比于《杰森一家》，反乌托邦式的未来电视剧要多得多。我们有吸尘器机器人。这非常有趣。我也不确定，如果听众对任何与《极乐空间》、《碳变》、《黑镜》相关的东西有什么推荐，我喜欢那些东西，我一直在寻找。《万神殿》，我想是《万神殿》。我想《万神殿》，还有动画，取决于它是如何被之前的播客嘉宾若昂推荐的，或者不是这个播客，而是Raycast。那不是完全反乌托邦的。它是关于成为
an uploaded intelligence, so you can go through an operation and have your brain zapped, and then you're living in the cloud. That's the transhumanism thing that doesn't sound all bad to me, folks. Kevlin has something to... Oh, it's not about the transhumanism. It's just one of the things that we mentioned in the talk, I was just thinking in terms of the dystopianism is that dystopianism isn't new, but it
一个上传的智能，所以你可以通过手术，让你的大脑被电击，然后你生活在云端。这就是那个听起来对我来说并不坏的超人类主义，伙计们。凯夫林有话要说……哦，这不是关于超人类主义。这只是我们在演讲中提到的事情之一，我只是在考虑反乌托邦主义，反乌托邦主义并不新鲜，但它
had a different meaning in the past, so therefore some of these same things taken out of context or put in a different context mean something different. So for example, historically a lot of the stuff that we associate with a kind of a cyberpunk future, things like altered carbon, if you go back to
在过去有不同的含义，因此其中一些相同的东西脱离了上下文或被置于不同的上下文中意味着不同的东西。例如，历史上我们与某种赛博朋克未来联系在一起的很多东西，比如《碳变》，如果你回到
kind of Blade Runner and things like that, most of the ideas, although they did touch on certain possibilities of the future in terms of corporatism, and politics. They were very, they were very, very gentle by comparison. They were mostly thematic. So in other words, a lot of the ideas, like we're going to adopt this, as a visualization, as a style, as a feel within the story, not necessarily. Alien Earth is actually quite a good example because you now have this, you know, it's a fully fledged idea of the dominance of
比如《银翼杀手》之类的东西，大多数想法，尽管它们确实触及了未来在公司主义和政治方面的某些可能性。相比之下，它们非常、非常温和。它们大多是主题性的。换句话说，很多想法，就像我们要采用这个，作为一种视觉化，作为一种风格，作为故事中的一种感觉，不一定。地球异形实际上是一个很好的例子，因为你现在有了这个，你知道，这是一个关于统治的完全成熟的想法
corporations. The original alien didn't really have that. That's something that's emerged over time. the corporate ideas just become a bigger, bigger thing. And we've kind of grown into it. We've got the louder background music now, folks. So you'll probably still be able to hear us, but the audio quality may or may not have just declined. I'm not sure why that is necessary. Anyways, it should be fine.
公司。最初的《异形》并没有真正拥有那个。那是随着时间推移而出现的。公司理念变得越来越大。我们已经成长为这样了。我们现在有更大的背景音乐了，伙计们。所以你们可能仍然能听到我们的声音，但音频质量可能已经下降了，也可能没有。我不确定为什么这是必要的。总之，应该没问题。
But yes, go watch the talk. I mean, I'm sure we still have a day and a half left. I'm sure it'll get talked about some more. But it is, I think, a very, very interesting conversation and, like, societally important, right? I am pretty sure, except for maybe a few of the billionaires out there, nobody wants to live in a world with, you know, income inequality skyrocketing and people being left behind because, you know,
但是是的，去看看那个演讲。我的意思是，我相信我们还有一天半的时间。我相信它会被更多地讨论。但我认为，这是一次非常、非常有趣的对话，而且，在社会层面上很重要，对吧？我很确定，除了少数亿万富翁之外，没有人想生活在一个收入不平等飙升、人们被抛在后面的世界里，因为，你知道，
AI is a tool that half of society can take advantage of, and the other half it's just going to hurt their circumstances. I think the majority of society can agree that we do not want that. And, you know, talks like this start conversations, and, you know, I had never really thought about the fact. You know, for the longest time, I just thought I was on the good side. You know, I always thought I was, I was about to say a Jedi, but then there's some people out there that have theories that the Jedi are actually the bad guy.
人工智能是一种半个社会可以利用的工具，而另一半社会只会损害他们的处境。我认为大多数社会可以同意我们不想要那样。而且，你知道，这样的演讲开启了对话，而且，你知道，我从来没有真正想过这个事实。你知道，很长一段时间里，我只是认为我站在好的一边。你知道，我总是认为我是，我正要说绝地武士，但外面有些人有理论认为绝地武士实际上是坏人。
I'm not sure if you got to take on that. Kevlin wore a Star Wars Hawaiian shirt in his second edition in Brisbane. Also, have you seen the Jarger Binks YouTube video theory? I'll send that to you later if you haven't where it was George Lucas's had this like symmetry and the Yoda of the prequel trilogy was supposed to be Jar Jar and was a drunken boxing, you know, Sith Lord that was, so it had all this compilates. If you haven't seen it, folks, and you're a Star Wars head, or even if you're not a Star Wars head, link in the show notes, that's some of the best fan detective work.
我不确定你对此有什么看法。凯夫林在布里斯班的第二版中穿了一件星球大战夏威夷衬衫。另外，你看过贾贾·宾克斯的YouTube视频理论吗？如果你还没看过，我稍后会发给你，那是乔治·卢卡斯有这种对称性，前传三部曲中的尤达本应该是贾贾，是一个醉拳，你知道，西斯尊主，所以它有所有这些复杂性。如果你还没看过，伙计们，如果你是星球大战迷，或者即使你不是星球大战迷，节目笔记中有链接，那是一些最好的粉丝侦探工作。
And I personally do think that Jar Jar was a Sith. But George Lucas got so much blowback on the character. He just had to abandon it. Have you seen that? Do you have theories? Or what's your wildness? Because we've been talking a lot about Andorfor. folks. Kevlin, huge Andor fan, huge Star Wars fan, maybe a little Star Wars to wrap up
我个人确实认为贾贾是西斯。但乔治·卢卡斯在这个角色上受到了太多的反弹。他不得不放弃它。你看过那个吗？你有什么理论吗？或者你的疯狂想法是什么？因为我们一直在谈论安多，伙计们。凯夫林，巨大的安多粉丝，巨大的星球大战粉丝，也许再来一点星球大战来结束
this episode. What do you want to tell the people? I don't have a specific take on Jar Jar Binks except that I used to be a big fan of machete order, which mostly, you know, if you're not familiar with that, just go and look that up online. Machete order Star Wars, which basically excluded most of the Jar Jar Binks material. Ultimately, Jar Jar did cause, he called for the vote that ultimately caused the collapse of the Republic and led to the foundation of the Galactic Empire.
这一集。你想告诉大家什么？我对贾贾·宾克斯没有特别的看法，除了我曾经是“弯刀顺序”的忠实粉丝，这主要是，你知道，如果你不熟悉那个，就去网上查一下。弯刀顺序星球大战，它基本上排除了大部分贾贾·宾克斯的材料。最终，贾贾确实导致了，他呼吁投票，最终导致了共和国的崩溃，并导致了银河帝国的建立。
So, you know, I think he's more pivotal than people give him credit for. What degree of intention he had, I'm going to leave that one to other fans, but if you want a wonderful breakdown of how revolutions start, and the moral grey areas
所以，你知道，我认为他比人们给予他的评价更关键。他有多少意图，我将把那个留给其他粉丝，但如果你想要一个关于革命如何开始以及道德灰色地带的精彩分析，
that a revolutionaries inhabit and or is absolutely the one to watch. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening.
革命者居住的地方，安多绝对是值得一看的。请务必在你的播客应用程序或ADSP the podcast.com上查看这些节目笔记，获取我们在今天这一集中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。